je suis le premier président mes chers
collègues
voici presque un hémicycle
n'est ce pas devant nous formé de
sénateurs qui vont être particulièrement
attentif aux travaux de la cour des
comptes
ce sont les deux ce que j'oserais appelé
les deux commissions financières
puisqu'il y à deux lois financières
maîtresse la loi de finances et la loi
de financement de la sécurité sociale
la présidente annie david va nous
rejoindre dans quelques instants
et nous avons nos deux rapporteurs
généraux n'est ce pas françois marque et
yves daudigny qui vont être
particulièrement attentifs et qui ne
manqueront pas très certainement de
poser
des questions de même que les uns et les
autres et sur le premier président il ya
une caractéristique de nos réunions dans
la salle clémenceau la salle clémenceau
elle n'est pas comme nos salles de
commissions traditionnels on n'a pas
encore véritablement totalement pris ses
marques puisque les membres des
différents groupes peuvent se rassembler
où se mêler les uns aux autres alors
qu'en salles de commissions on ne le
fait jamais c'est comme la commission
des finances de l'assemblée nationale
il y a en quelque sorte une morphologie
des lieux avec les implantations des
différents groupes
quand on siège hanks halle clemenceau on
a perdu quelques-uns de nous de nos
repères sans doute pour le meilleur
peut-être pour le pire je ne sais pas
mais en tout cas ceci nous permet de
bénéficier de l'équipement de cette
salle et nos travaux sont donc des
travaux publics ce matin et c'est bien
naturel puisque la cour des comptes
le réviseur des comptes de l'état
le certificateur des comptes de l'état
exerce en début de législature pour la
première fois de façon aussi formel sa
mission d'éclairage d'identification des
sujets de formulation des observations
et des recommandations qui sont
nécessaires à l'état pour la période à
venir
monsieur le premier président le rapport
que vous allez commenter a déjà été
rendue publique
vous venez de l'assemblée nationale dont
la commission des finances est à nouveau
opérationnel depuis quelques jours et
sans plus attendre j'ai le plaisir de
vous passer la parole à vrai dire nous
serions surpris qu'il y ait des
désaccords ou des incohérences par
rapport à ce que vous nous avez déjà dit
dans la précédente audition qui portait
sur la gestion 2011
mais le rapport que vous nous présentez
à un horizon plus vaste une perspective
plus longue et bien entendu toutes et
tous nous sommes très attentifs à vos
propos à la suite desquels nous nous
efforcerons de débattre
merci monsieur le président monsieur le
président ce le rapporteur général de la
commission des finances sur le
rapporteur général de la commission des
affaires sociales mesdames et messieurs
les sénateurs
je vous remercie monsieur le président
d'avoir organisé cette audition elles
permettent à la cour de vous livrer son
analyse destinée à nourrir le débat
d'orientation des finances publiques
mais aussi ceux qui auront lieu
prochainement lors des discussions
successives de la wattine ans
rectificative de la prochaine loi de
programmation des finances publiques et
des lois de finances et de financement
de la sécurité sociale pour 2013
vous le savez vous venez de le rappeler
l'une des missions de notre juridiction
et de vous faire part de ces constats
analyses préconisations sur la situation
des finances publiques et à travers ces
rapports prévus par la lolf mais aussi
les enquêtes que vous nous demandez
chaque année les travaux d'évaluation
des politiques publiques
nous livrons au parlement ainsi que les
rapports thématiques référé rapports
particuliers dont vous prenez
connaissance la cour rempli sa mission
d'assistance au gouvernement pour le
contrôle de l'action du gouvernement
comme elle accomplit également une
mission d'assistance pour le
gouvernement une mission d'information
du citoyen alors je suis accompagné de
raoul briet président de la première
chambre de la cour et de la formation
intershop sur les finances publiques de
jean marie bertrand président de chambre
à porter général denis morin qui était
le rapporteur général de la formation
intershop sur ce rapport et françois
ecalle qui en était le rapporteur de
synthèse
l'audition de ce matin s'inscrit dans un
contexte particulier au lendemain de la
publication du rapport sur les finances
publiques dont je n'oublie pas que le
premier destinataire et le parlement il
inclut cette année une évaluation
détaillée répondant à une demande du
premier ministre
des risques pesant sur la fin de la
gestion 2012 et des enjeux qui sont
associées pour les années suivantes au
respect de la trajectoire de retour à
l'équilibré des comptes publics et dans
le cadre de la procédure contradictoire
le gouvernement a eu connaissance d'une
version provisoire du rapport dès le 22
juin
il a donc pu tirer parti de cette
analyse avant de prendre les arbitrages
qui lui reviennent
élaborer le projet de loi de finances
rectificative que vous examinerez très
prochainement et qui sera soumis à votre
approbation je crois que vous
auditionner les ministres également dans
l'après midi
bonjour madame la présidente voilà avant
tout je souhaite insister sur l'enjeu
que représente pour la france à ce
moment de son histoire le retour à
l'équilibré durable de ses comptes
publics n'ayant pas assuré depuis plus
de 30 ans l'équilibré de ses comptes ne
serait-ce qu'une année même en période
de forte croissance la france est entrée
dans la crise avec une dette trop élevée
et des comptes en déficit structurel au
cours des dix années qui ont précédé la
crise les engagements européens de
redressement des comptes non poisy ment
jamais été tenus par notre pays
maintes fois le retour à l'équilibré des
comptes a été annoncée sans cesse
différée alors que les contextes
économiques ont pu être favorable en
certaines circonstances à un tel
rétablissement
cette situation a nui
à la crédibilité de la france à l'égard
de ses partenaires européens
au plus fort de la crise en 2009 le
déficit public a atteint le niveau
historique de 140 2 milliards d'euros la
dette a vivement progressé pour
atteindre fin 2011 86 % du pib' alors
qu'elle était de 64 % en 2007 et de 46%
en 1993 cette dette 2007 117 milliards
d'euros 31 décembre 2011 représente 60
de 1000 euros par ménage à ce niveau
proche de 90% qui devrait d'ailleurs
être dépassé à la fin de l'année 2012 ou
au début de l'année 2013
le pays est dans une zone dangereuse
pour son économie comme pour ses
finances publiques
en effet le risque d'un emballement de
la dette ne peut être écartée la crise
des dettes souveraines en europe
montrent que ce risque n'est pas
théorique il se réalise malheureusement
pour des états voisins d'une autre et se
manifeste par une hausse brutale des
taux d'intérêt demandés sur les emprunts
publics de telles situations conduisent
les états concernés à des choix
économiques et sociaux drastiques qui
finissent par leur être imposée de
l'extérieur afin que ce risque ne se
concrétise pas il convient que la france
reste hors sa crédibilité respecte la
trajectoire de financement qu'elle s'est
fixés qui passe par un déficit de 4,4
pour cent du pib en 2012 puis 2 puis le
programme de stabilité par un déficit de
3% du pib en 2013 pour atteindre
l'équilibré en 2016 ou 2017
tout écart prix par rapport à cette
trajectoire porterait atteinte à la
crédibilité de la france et pourrait
déclencher une dynamique insoutenable de
l'augmentation de notre endettement est
simultanément
l'incapacité à le financer dans des
conditions supportables
si l inverse la france tient ses
engagements trois années de suite en
ayant connu ailleurs une alternance la
confiance la crédibilité du pays ne
pourront qu'être conforter sa dépendance
à l'égard des marchés financiers réduite
et sa capacité de peser efficacement sur
la scène européenne renforce
d'autres raisons militent pour le retour
à l'équilibré rapide des comptes publics
la première est le niveau atteint par la
charge d'intérêt des administrations
publiques
je rappelle le chiffre 50 2,6 milliards
d'euros
elle prive notre pays d'importantes
marges de manoeuvre qui lui manquent
particulièrement en période de crise
plus le redressement sera tardif plus il
sera difficile à conduire agira 1 coûte
la courbe le reconnaît le disons dans
notre rapporte ne pas agir en a un
selon nous encore plus grand parce
qu'entre temps la dette et la charge
d'intérêt auront continué à progresser
enfin le niveau de la dette pose une
question d'équité entre les générations
car cette date correspond pour
l'essentiel à des dépenses de
fonctionnement n'ont rien ne justifie
que la charge soit transférée sur les
générations les plus jeunes l'analyse de
la cour a montré qu'en 2010 les deux
tiers du déficit public était
indépendant de la crise et présentait un
caractère structurel ce déficit
structurel héritées du passé était déjà
eu 3 5% du pib en 2007 il était très
proche de 4% en 2011 et ses quatre
points de pivot 80 milliards d'euros
représente le chemin à parcourir d'ici
2016 2017 pour garantir un retour à
l'équilibré des comptes
indépendamment de la conjoncture
économique la cour n'ignore pas que ce
nécessaire effort de rééquilibrage peut
comporter un effet négatif à court terme
sur la croissance
mais cet effet négatif peut être limité
par un dosage approprié des mesures de
redressement et par une initiative de
croissance au niveau européen il doit
surtout être relativisée gelé dit à
l'instant par rapport aux effets
beaucoup plus graves et durables que
comporterait une sortie de la
trajectoire de retour à l'équilibré
les mesures de rééquilibrage doivent
être justement réparti entre les
différents acteurs économiques elles
doivent par ailleurs préserver la
compétitivité de l'économie française
comme la cour l'a montré dans un rapport
établissant une comparaison des systèmes
de prélèvements obligatoires entre la
france et l'allemagne
le gouvernement doit en effet s'attacher
à réduire simultanément non pas un non
pas un mais deux déficits
celui de ses comptes publics et de sa
compétitivité et réduire la n'est pas
exclusif de la réalisation de l'autre
l'année 2011 a représenté une première
étape dans le redressement des comptes
publics
le déficit public s'est établi à 5,2
pour cent du pif 63 milliards d'euros
cette baisse résulte pour plus de 40% de
la fin des mesures temporaires comme le
plan de relance de 2009 et 2010 le
déficit structurel s'est replié de 0,9
point de pipe principalement par l'effet
de mesures fiscales les règles
budgétaires notamment les normes de
dépenses appliquant au budget de l'état
ou dépenses d'assurance maladie ainsi
qu'au transfert de l'état vers les
collectivités territoriales ont été
respectées les comptes 2011 se situe sur
la trajectoire de redressement des
comptes
néanmoins la france n'a pas rattrapé son
retard par rapport aux autres pays
européens qui eux mêmes sont engagés
dans la voie de la réduction des
déficits souvent un rythme plus rapide
que la france le déficit structurel de
2011 de 4% du peep se disent se situe au
dessus de la moyenne des autres états
membres de la zone euro qui s'élève à
3,2 il demeure très supérieur au déficit
structurel allemand de 0,8 pour cent des
niveaux de dette français et allemands
divergent
dorénavant et c'est une évolution
nouvelle et inquiétante
en france la dette continue d'augmenter
car le déficit est le double de celui
qui stabilise la dette
le rapport de la dette dans la richesse
nationale est devenu supérieur à celui
de l'allemagne alors que ce dernier
entame son repli en 2012 la france est
engagée en avril dernier à revenir à un
déficit de 4 4% après 5,2 en 2011
la cour a cherché à apprécier
au regard des informations disponibles à
ce stade de l'année et compte non tenu
j insiste là-dessus des mesures décidées
après le 6 mai 2012
si cet objectif de 4,4 pour cent pouvait
être tenu
or il ne s'agit pas d'un pronostic sur
le solde qui sera atteint en fin d'année
mais d'une analyse des risques qui
pèsent sur l'année 2012 comme l'a
souhaité le premier ministre compte non
tenu j'assiste des mesures nouvelles
dont le financement devra par ailleurs
être assurée l'analyse de la cour montre
que le respect de la trajectoire pour
2012 est possible mais suppose des
mesures rapides de correction en raison
de moins-values probable de recettes
or s'agissant en premier lieu des
dépenses les travaux conduits par la
cour ont identifié des risques de
déplacement sur certaines dépenses de
l'état notamment les dépenses de
personnel et d'opérations extérieures du
ministère de la défense le dépenses de
logement en particulier l'aide
personnalisée au logement ou les
dépenses relatives à l'allocation adulte
handicapé et plus largement les
dotations pour l'emploi et la solidarité
vous retrouvez tous ces dépassements
identifiés dans les annexes du rapport
ont également été identifiés d'autres
risques dont l'ampleur peut être
significative à l'échelle des programmes
budgétaires auxquelles ils appartiennent
mais dont le montant n'est pas
significatif par rapport aux enjeux de
la maîtrise du budget de l'état dans son
longtemps dans son ensemble au total les
risques de dépassements peuvent être
estimés à un niveau compris entre 1 et 2
milliards d'euros
je le rappelle sur un total de 275
milliards d'euros hors dette et pensions
un tel niveau de risque ne se démarque
pas de ceux couramment identifiés en
cours d'année à l'occasion des exercices
précédents
ces risques peuvent et doivent être
selon nous résolu en gestion par le jeu
des annulations et des reports de
crédits si les possibles dépassements ne
sont pas d'une ampleur exceptionnelle il
s'applique toutefois un budget
particulièrement serré le respect des
normes de dépenses fixes et suppose une
grande vigilance afin que les
déplacements identifiés ne soient pas
couverts par des ouvertures de crédits
mais par la mobilisation de la réserve
de précaution dont le montant actuel de
5 milliards d'euros environ ce qui rend
nécessaire un accroissement de cette
réserve de l'ordre
milliards d'euros pour permettre le
pilotage fin de l'exécution en matière
d'assurance maladie le parlement a voté
une progression des dépenses d'assurance
maladie ce que l'on appelle l'ondam de
2,5 en 2012
l'ondam réalisés en 2011 a été en fait
inférieur d'environ 500 millions d'euros
par rapport au montant voté
compte tenu de cet effet de base la
progression réelle de l'ondam en 2012
celle vrai à 2,7 et non 2,5
la cour recommande de viser en exécution
de progression de l'ondam pour 2012 de
2,5 par rapport aux dépenses
effectivement constatés en 2011 la mise
en oeuvre complète des mesures
d'économies engagées ainsi qu'une
gestion rigoureuse des gels de crédits
dans le secteur hospitalier qui est de
l'ordre de 415 millions milliards
d'euros devrait permettre millions
pardon d'euros devrait permettre
d'atteindre cette cible et 415 milliards
bien
s'agissant des collectivités
territoriales n'existe malheureusement
aucun outil fiable permettant de suivre
en cours d'année l'exécution de leur
budget les incertitudes portent
essentiellement sur leurs dépenses
d'investissement la prévision inscrite
dans le programme de stabilité d'avril
nous apparaît plausible mais il existe
un aléa de l'ordre de 0,1 point de pub
qui peut affecter le déficit des
administrations publiques dans un sens
ou dans l'autre
concernant la recette la cour a
identifié des risques importants de
moins value qui appelle sans tarder des
mesures correctrices ces risques sont
d'une double nature d'une part des
hypothèses de calcul trop favorables ont
été adoptées pour l'évaluation initiale
du produit des prélèvements obligatoires
il s'agit notamment des hypothèses
d'élasticité c'est à dire des
estimations de la façon dont le produit
d'un impôt évolue en fonction de la
croissance
elles ont conduit en particulier à
surestimer le produit de l'impôt sur les
sociétés à ce stade il est difficile
d'évaluer l'impact de cette
surestimation la cour la situe dans une
fourchette comprise entre 3 et 7
milliards pour l'ensemble des recettes
des administrations publiques
d'autre part le scénario macroéconomique
retenu en avril reposait sur un niveau
croissance de 0,7 tu pouvais être en
phase avec les prévisions des organismes
internationaux en raison de la
dégradation récente de la conjoncture ce
scénario est devenu trop optimistes les
dernières prévisions de l'insee situe le
taux de croissance pour 2010 à 0,4 ce
qui réduit mécaniquement les prévisions
de recettes de 3 milliards d'euros
supplémentaires
le gouvernement a fait savoir qu'il
retenait une hypothèse 0,3 pour cent au
total les recettes pourraient donc être
inférieur de 6 à 10 milliards d'euros au
montant prévu dans le programme de
stabilité
ces estimations encore fragile pourront
être précisées au vu notamment de
données relatives aux rentrées fiscales
disponible dans le courant du mois de
juillet le respect de l'objectif de
déficit public pour 2012 fixé à 4,4 nous
apparaît essentiel car les efforts à
fournir en 2013 sont suffisamment
importants pour ne pas prendre de retard
en 2012 face au risque identifié des
mesures nouvelles doivent être
rapidement prises en recettes et en
dépenses avant d'aborder les enjeux de
l'année 2013
je souhaite évoquer un sujet qui aura un
impact budgétaire important sur
plusieurs exercices il s'agit de deux
contentieux perdu par l'état devant les
juridictions européennes
l'un portant sur le précompte mobilier
et l'autre sur la fiscalité des
dividendes versés à des organismes de
placements en valeurs mobilières
ce que l'on appelle les opcvm non
résidents sans entrer dans le détail
l'un des deux le second n'a pas été
intégré dans le budget pour 2012 alors
qu'il existait une forte probabilité que
le contentieux soit perdue et entraîne
des remboursements dès cet exercice les
conséquences en comptabilité nationale
de ces deux contentieux devrait peser
surtout sur les années 2013 à hauteur de
5,75 milliards d'euros et 2014 pour 1,75
milliard d'euros soit au total 7
milliards et demi la cour juge anormal
que les informations qui avaient conduit
en 2011 approvisionner le contentieux
opcvm en comptabilité générale n'ait pu
de traduction ni sur les lois de
finances pour 2012 en tout cas
suffisamment
ni dans le cadre du programme de
stabilité au total le respect de
l'objectif de déficit de 4 4% du pib en
2012 suppose de compenser un manque à
gagner de recettes de 6 à 10 milliards
d'euros
j'en viens maintenant perspectives pour
l'année 2013 et pour les années
suivantes
même si les incertitudes sont encore
nombreuses la prévision de croissance de
1,75 pour cent pour l'année 2013 fixé en
avril dernier par est aujourd'hui hors
de portée la cour a quantifié les
efforts à accomplir selon quatre
scénarios que vous retrouvez donc dans
le rapport de croissance allant de 0 à
2%
dans l'hypothèse de 1% de croissance
afin d'atteindre les 3% de déficit la
marche sera plus haute que les années
précédentes
après 0,9 point de réduction du déficit
structurel en 2011 et 1,2 point en 2012
l'effort structurel à réaliser et de 1,6
point en 2013 soit 33 milliards d'euros
compte non tenu de l'impact budgétaire
des contentieux dont j'ai parlé à
hauteur de l'ordre de 5 milliards 75 /
bon sauf si un étalement différents
pouvaient être mises en place
si les objectifs sont tenues la plus
grande partie du chemin a réalisé depuis
2010 aura été parcouru sur les cinq
points de pub a effacé par rapport à
2010 plus de trois et demi lors on était
c'est dire l'importance pour la
crédibilité de notre pays de tenir
l'engagement pour 2013 cet effort peut
sembler important il est cependant de
même ampleur que celui que la france a
réalisé pour se qualifier pour entrer
dans l'union monétaire en 1997 dans un
contexte économique quelque peu
différent or se pose la question du
partage de cet effort entre réduction du
poids des dépenses publiques et recettes
supplémentaires le rapport présente
plusieurs hypothèses
la cour a toujours considéré ce n'est
pas nouveau que le levier de la maîtrise
des dépenses devaient jouer un rôle
essentiel mais si l'on retient par
exemple un partage égal entre mesures
sur les recettes
mesures sur les dépenses ce sont 16
milliard et demi d'économies sur les
dépenses qui devront être réalisés par
rapport à leur évolution tendancielle
un tel effort reviendrait à stabilisé en
volume les dépenses publiques dans leur
ensemble c'est-à-dire faire en sorte
qu'elle n'évolue pas plus vite que
l'inflation
par comparaison en 2012 en dépit de
l'application des normes de dépenses et
de la réduction des effectifs de
fonctionnaires de l'état
la dépense publique totale dans son
ensemble devrait croître en volume de
0,5 pour cent
la cour évoque dans le rapport
différentes modalités de répartition de
cet effort global entre l'état la
sécurité sociale et les collectivités
territoriales
le premier scénario est celui d'une
stabilisation volume de toutes les
dépenses des administrations publiques
qui conduirait les administrations de
sécurité sociale à fournir un lourd et
fort car ce sont leurs dépenses qui
affiche les croissance tendancielle bien
évidemment les plus fortes
un autre scénario prévoit de réduire
l'effort sur ce secteur par exemple en
laissant croître les dépenses de 1,2
pour cent en volume dans ce cas les
dépenses de l'état devraient être
stabilisés en valeur ce qui conduirait
un durcissement des normes de dépenses
appliquée en 2012 il dans ces scénarios
les dépenses des collectivités
territoriales devrait être stabilisé en
volume
je voudrais insister sur les enjeux qui
s'attache à l'implication de toutes les
administrations dans le respect des
engagements de la france en matière de
finances
en effet le fait que les collectivités
territoriales et des comptes
structurellement équilibré ne saurait
les dispenser selon nous de participer à
l'effort collectif
les engagements européens de la france
porte en effet sur une trajectoire de
déficit cohérente avec une évolution
donner des dépenses publiques et des
prélèvements obligatoires
il est donc essentiel que sur ces trois
points les engagements nationaux piste
un piquet chaque secteur
d'administration publique
or en l'état actuel de la gouvernance de
nos finances publiques plus du quart des
administrations publiques échappe aux
contraintes
pacte de stabilité ainsi les
collectivités territoriales les régimes
complémentaires de retraite l'assurance
chômage peuvent définir leurs objectifs
financiers
sans prendre en compte les engagements
de la nation s'agissant des
collectivités territoriales la
croissance de leurs dépenses hors impact
des compétences transférées par l'état a
été très rapide au cours des dernières
années même si elle s'est infléchie en
2010 avant de repartir à la hausse en
2011 hors transferts de compétences
leurs effectifs se sont accrus de plus
de 260 milles poste depuis 2002 dont
près des trois quarts concernent les
communes et intercommunalités
cette croissance doit être mise en
regard de l'évolution des effectifs de
l'état sur la même période qui après
avoir diminué de l'ordre de 25 mille
agents entre 2002 et 2007 ont décru de
150 mille agents depuis cette date
or le seul instrument d'action de l'état
à l'égard des collectivités
territoriales consiste à freiner
l'évolution de ces concours qui
atteignent 100 milliards d'euros et
représente près de la moitié des
ressources des collectivités
la moitié de ces concours soit 50
milliards d'euros sont aujourd'hui gelée
en valeur ce qui fait désormais peser
une contrainte plus forte sur
l'évolution de leurs dépenses mais les
effets de cette contrainte sont
variables selon le niveau de
collectivité contraintes très élevé sur
les départements
élevé sur les régions faibles sur les
communes et intercommunalités qui sont
par ailleurs les seuls à disposer encore
d'une marge de manoeuvre fiscale
après les dernières réformes en la
matière la cour recommande une poursuite
de ce gel tout temps
renforçant la contrainte qui pèserait
sur les communes et les
intercommunalités l'accroissement des
dépenses des collectivités au cours des
deux dernières décennies a été financée
par une hausse concomitante des impôts
locaux réduisant ainsi la capacité
contributive des ménages le contribuable
et 1 et rendant plus difficile des
augmentations d'impôt en faveur des
autres administrations publiques qu'il
s'agisse de l'êta ou de la sécurité
sociale cela montre que la gestion
d'ensemble des finances publiques
appellent désormais l'élaboration de
règles partagées sur l'évolution des
dépenses et sur la répartition des
recettes ainsi une stratégie devrait
être adoptée au niveau des
administrations publiques dans leur
ensemble
associant chaque catégorie à la
définition et à la mise en oeuvre des
objectifs de maîtrise des dépenses et de
modération des prélèvements ceci rend
nécessaire selon nous la mise en place
d'une gouvernance partagée des
administrations publiques reposant sur
un cadre normatif ou contractuels
assurant la cohérence globale le respect
des engagements pris par la france est
la juste répartition des efforts à cette
fin un pacte de stabilité pourrait être
conclu entre l'état et les collectivités
territoriales afin d'engager celle ci
dans le respect de la trajectoire
globale définie pour le pays
dans cette même perspective le champ des
lois de financement de la sécurité
sociale pourrait être élargie à
l'assurance chômage et au régime de
retraite complémentaire pour devenir de
véritables lois de financement de la
protection sociale
si l'effort doit porter sur toutes les
administrations publiques
il revient bien sûr au gouvernement et
au parlement de 2
d'apprécier quelle est la part qui
revient à chacun il doit également
concerner toutes les catégories de
dépenses en le principal enjeu
budgétaire porte sur la masse salariale
en effet ces dépenses y compris des
pensions représente 13,2 pour cent du
pipe toute administration confondus la
masse salariale de l'état s'élève à 80
milliards d'euros et connaît une
croissance une croissance tendancielle
soutenu 1,6 pour cent par an dans le
cadre d'une stabilité des effectifs
même si vous ne bougez pas vous avez
votre masse salariale qui évolue deux un
lien d'une scie boursault le respect de
la trajectoire de redressement des
comptes publics implique que la masse
salariale de l'état
de plus toujours si on veut respecter
les objectifs de l'état soient
stabilisés en valeur pour l'exercice
2013 pour vous vous aider dans vos
réflexions la cour a présenté quatre
scénarios permettant chacun de
stabiliser la masse salariale chacun
d'eux utilisant de façon variable
les quatre levier que constitue
l'évolution des effectifs
la valeur du point d'indicé les
déroulements de carrière et les mesures
catégorielles
je me contenterai de commenter deux de
ces scénarios le premier envisage une
poursuite du gel du point d'indicé et de
la réduction des effectifs de 30 mille
postes par an il permet de ne pas peser
sur les déroulements de carrière des
agents publics et sur les mesures
catégorielles le second scénario repose
à l'invers sur une stabilisation des
effectifs
cette hypothèse nécessite outre la
poursuite du gel du point d'indicé une
réduction significative de l'avancement
des fonctionnaires et un quasi gel des
mesures catégorielles
pour résumer seule une baisse des
effectifs est à même de fournir des
marges de manoeuvre en matière de
politique salariale
s'agissant des dépenses d'intervention
elle représente 620 milliards d'euros
sur un total de 1100 20 milliards
d'euros de dépenses soit 55%
sur ce total les re prestations sociales
représentent 81 2% soit 510 milliards
d'euros elle concerne l'ensemble des
collectivités publiques
l'état pour 150 milliards d'euros il
convient avant tout de développer selon
nous une démarche une démarche
d'évaluation de l'efficacité et de
l'efficience de l'action publique dans
ce domaine il s'agit d'adopter une
approche par politiques publiques et non
par dispositif d'intervention ou par
acteurs les politiques d'intervention
sont aujourd'hui partagés entre l'état
et les diverses collectivités publiques
avec un enchevêtrement des compétences
qui peut nuire à leur efficacité
par exemple en matière de formation de
logement ou d'emploi beaucoup de travaux
montrent que le rapport coût-efficacité
n'est pas le plus performant
cela suppose de s'interroger sur
l'articulation entre les divers acteurs
et dispositifs dont le nombre dépasse
1300 des exemples concrets
d'intervention redondantes et mal
coordonnés dont inefficiente peuvent
être trouvées dans le rapport
dans les secteurs que je viens d'évoquer
des marges de manoeuvre qu'offrent
dossier de trouver pour améliorer
l'efficacité économique et le ciblage
sociale des dispositifs publics de
solidarité or de telles évaluations
suppose
à la différence de la révision générale
des politiques publiques d'associer
toutes les parties prenantes et de faire
partager les diagnostics et les réformes
envisagées tout en adoptant un pilotage
politique fort pour mener à bien ses
projets la cour en exerçant sa mission
d'évaluation des politiques publiques à
l'intention du parlement et du
gouvernement pourra prendre sa part à
cette revue des politiques
d'intervention en y associant les
chambres régionales et territoriales des
comptes de même devant les chevaux de
nos politiques publiques source de
complexité de gaspillage l'acte iii de
la décentralisation qui est annoncée
doit être avant tout pour vous
l'occasion d'une clarification des
compétences entre l'état et
collectivités territoriales ainsi quand
les collectivités territoriales elle
même ils devraient être guidées par le
souci premier d'améliorer l'efficience
des politiques concernés les dépenses de
transfert concerne aussi la sécurité
sociale le rééquilibrage des comptes
sociaux doit être assurée en priorité la
cour a rappelé régulièrement que
l'existence même du dette sociale
elle constitue une anomalie profonde car
les dépenses de soins n'ont pas de
raison d'être reporter sur les
générations futures
le système de retraite ne devrait pas
connaître le retour à l'équilibré prévu
par la réforme de 2010 en raison des
prévisions trop optimistes notamment en
matière d'évolution de la situation de
l'emploi
ainsi le déficit annuel de l'ensemble
des régimes de retraite pourrait être
supérieur à 10 milliards d'euros à
l'horizon 2020 la question du
rééquilibrage des comptes devra donc
prochainement être examinée par vous
même pour l'assurance-maladie également
les efforts doivent être amplifiées en
effet la poursuite d'une croissance des
dépenses d'assurance-maladie de 3 %
chaque année sans l'apport de recettes
nouvelles conduirait à un retour à
l'équilibré en 2024 seulement si ce taux
de croissance merci été ramené à 2,5
pour cent le retour à l'équilibré serait
atteint en 2018 le système de soins peut
être rendu plus efficient sans perte de
chance pour les malades en améliorant la
coordination entre professionnels de
santé entre médecine de ville l'hôpital
en renforçant les bonnes pratiques de
soins et en maîtrisant plus efficacement
certaines dépenses le rapport annuel de
la cour sur la sécurité sociale fourni
de nombreuses pistes de réforme en ce
sens nous espérons que le prochain que
nous aurons à vous présenter en
septembre en comportera également
s'agissant enfin des dépenses
d'investissement l'ampleur des
engagements envisagée ou déjà pris doit
conduire à réexaminer leur compatibilité
avec le retour à l'équilibré des comptes
publics
il importe vraisemblablement de mieux
choisir les investissements publics pour
ne retenir que ceux qui auront fait la
preuve de leur utilité notamment au
regard du relèvement de la croissance
potentielle de l'économie
la cour préconise la mise en place d'une
expertise indépendante des opérateurs en
matière d'études de rentabilité
socio-économique et une meilleure prise
en compte de celle ci dans les choix et
la hiérarchisation des investissements
en janvier dernier en particulier la
cour a appelé à reconsidérer le
programme de développement de lignes
ferroviaires
à grande vitesse retenue dans le volet
transports du grenelle de
l'environnement qui entraînerait 166
milliards d'euros de dépenses publiques
nouvelles sans qu'elle soit à ce jour
financer l'investissement des
collectivités territoriales et des
hôpitaux devraient également respecter
ces principes action sur la dépense
action sur la recette l'augmentation des
recettes est inévitable pour compléter
l'effort elle devrait jouer dans le
processus de redressement un rôle pour
nous sensiblement moins important que la
réduction du poids des dépenses et des
croissants dans le temps elle doit
reposer principalement sur
l'élargissement de l'assiette des
prélèvements existants plutôt que sur
des hausses du taux pour des raisons
d'efficacité économique
il faut donc que vous puissiez
poursuivre selon nous le travail que
vous avez engagé sur la réduction et la
suppression des niches fiscales et
sociales
les rapports de la cour mais aussi
beaucoup de rapport du parlement
fournissent de multiples exemples de
niche pouvant être supprimés nous
pensons qu'il ya des marges de manoeuvre
sur celles en faveur de l'investissement
outre-mer où le taux réduit de tva sur
la restauration ou dont les plafonds
pourrait être abaissée comme la
réduction et le crédit d'impôt pour
l'emploi d'un salarié à domicile
si la réduction des niches ne suffisait
pas à dégager les recettes attendues et
j'insiste sur cette condition il
pourrait être nécessaire d'augmenter le
taux d'impôt à assiette large
c'est-à-dire la csg ou la tva
la première étant adaptée au
rééquilibrage des comptes sociaux dont
la cour souligne une nouvelle fois le
caractère absolument prioritaire une
telle augmentation devrait avoir un
caractère temporaire et s'effacer au fur
et à mesure du rééquilibrage des comptes
publics et de la montée en puissance des
économies sur les dépenses
après 2013 l'effort de redressement
devra se poursuivre un rythme moindre
afin de garantir le retour à l'équilibré
structurel en 2016 ou 2017 que
l'allemagne est en passe d'atteindre dès
notre pays se trouve à la fin à la
veille donc d'une profonde
transformation dans la conduite de ses
finances publiques sous l'effet des
nouvelles règles européennes adoptées
depuis 2011 d'ailleurs la prise en
compte de celle ci est loin de se
réduire au débat sur la règle du un
retour à l'équilibré structurel à moyen
terme ce qu'on appelle la règle d'or en
effet la série de dispositions qui est
adoptée conduira la france dans le
respect des pouvoirs bien sûr du
parlement a révisé la façon dont elle
élabore et suit les textes parce qu il
en rire un peu le pensons ces nouvelles
règles européennes appellent également
des progrès dans la qualité de nos
comptes publics
la france dispose en la matière d'une
avance par rapport à ses partenaires
européens dans la certification des
comptes de l'état et du régime général
de sécurité sociale par la cour des
comptes depuis six ans afin de
progresser dans la fiabilité des comptes
et dans leur harmonisation entre les
différentes catégories d'administration
publique
cette démarche de certification
gagnerait à être élargie la cour
recommande la mise en oeuvre concrète de
la certification des comptes des
hôpitaux publics déjà décidée par le
législateur j'ai eu l'occasion de
m'exprimer devant une de vos missions et
j'ai vu que cette idée avait été reprise
ainsi que la mise en place d'une
expérimentation de la certification des
comptes des plus grandes collectivités
territoriales si elles le souhaitent
par ailleurs l'autorité statistique
européenne eurostat considère que la
comptabilité nationale établie par
l'insee devraient s'appuyer sur une
comptabilité endroit constatez donc sur
la comptabilité générale de l'état et
non sa comptabilité budgétaire une
coopération renforcée entre la cour et
l'insee devrait contribuer à améliorer
la qualité de la comptabilité nationale
les mêmes règles européennes rendre
enfin nécessaire la mise en place d'une
gouvernance partagée des administrations
publiques
j'ai déjà évoqué ce sujet pour conclure
la france est loin d'être considérée
comme exemplaire dans la gestion de ses
finances publiques depuis plusieurs
décennies en 2011 un peu plus d'un mois
des dépenses de l'ensemble des
administrations publiques étaient
financées par l'emprunt pour l'état seul
cela représente même quatre mois dans le
contexte actuel de crise de la zone euro
afin de sécuriser le financement de
l'action publique d'éviter que le poids
de la dette
n'étouffe l'économie de continuer à
peser dans le concert européen de
restaurer des marges de manoeuvre pour
l'action publique et de sauvegarder la
cohésion entre générations la france
doit assurer le retour à l'équilibré
structurel de ses comptes publics dans
les quatre ou cinq prochaines années la
cour insiste sur l'importance du strict
respect de l'objectif et de l'engagement
de réduction du déficit à 3% en 2013 à
juste titre considérée comme une année
charnière pour le redressement des
comptes publics de la france
la discipline qui exige le respect de
cette trajectoire est sévère
elle suppose une évolution profondeur
des modalités de l'action publique
gouvernance partagée entre
administrations publiques application
généralisée des normes de dépenses
réforme en profondeur des méthodes
d'allocation des moyens remise en cause
peut être aussi de certaines missions de
l'état revue des politiques
d'intervention clarification des
compétences partagées entre l'état et
les collectivités territoriales
évaluation indépendante de l'utilité des
investissements voilà beaucoup de
travail pour vous cette discipline
implique également des choix difficiles
en matière de politique salariale et
d'évolution des effectifs dans les
fonctions publiques
de même de nombreux dispositifs qui
n'auront pas fait n'ont pas fait la
preuve de leur efficience devront être
réduits ou supprimés des projets
d'investissement retarder ou abandonnés
l'objectif de ces réformes doit être
expliquée bien évidemment c'est pourquoi
la cour tout en fournissant des pistes
d'économies précise insiste sur les
méthodes de réformes qui doivent
privilégier la pédagogie et la
transparence
l'effort structurel prévu en 2013 de
l'ordre d'un point de me de pim est
certes difficile
il est néanmoins atteignable le fmi
identifié dans le monde entre 1980 et
2009 une trentaine de consolidation
budgétaire de cette ampleur la france
l'a fait par le passé et en 2012
l'italie et l'espagne devraient de leur
côté réduire leur déficit structurel de
près de 3 points soit un effort double
nous espérons que cet audit des finances
publiques aura montré que le
redressement est exigeant qu'il suppose
la mobilisation de tous les acteurs
publics qu'il doit être réalisable est
réalisée sans étouffer la croissance
en contribuant à une meilleure prise de
conscience de ces enjeux par les
citoyens les décideurs en fournissant
nous l'espérons des pistes utiles à
l'action la cour des comptes assure
d'une certaine façon déjà la fonction de
comité budgétaire indépendant dont les
nouvelles règles européennes prévoit la
mise en place prochaine d'un autre pays
elle est en tout cas à la disposition du
parlement
je vous renouvelle sa disponibilité pour
jouer son rôle d'analysé de conseil et
s'exprime un peu si souvent que
nécessaire pour jouer pleinement ce rôle
de vigilance d'informations et de
conseils je vous remercie de votre
attention monsieur le président
messieurs les rapports que madame la
présidente monsieur les rapporteurs
généraux
nous sommes à votre disposition avec les
magistrats qui m'entourent pour répondre
aux questions que vous souhaiteriez nous
poser merci beaucoup monsieur le premier
président il est 12h 19h et nous avons
par conséquent un choix avant les choix
redoutable sur le fond nous avons un
choix sur la méthode et la procédure
soit nous considérons que cette audition
est une cérémonie
nous vous avons écouté nous vous
remercions
nous reconduisons nous vaquons à nos
occupations
soit nous estimons que ceci ouvre un
débat mais ouvrir un débat en moins de
trois quarts d'heure avec des
intervenants qui seront certainement
nombreux et qui légitimement ont besoin
de s'exprimer
c'est une gageur alors si vous le
souhaitez mais chers collègues nous
pouvons tenter le débat mais ce ne sera
qu'une toute première approche de débat
et qui nécessairement entraînera des
frustrations peut-être voulez-vous nous
habituer aux frustrations inévitable
dans la période qui vous attend non je
ne crois pas c'est simplement
l'enchaînement de l'horaire et de nos
ordres du jour là nous sommes à votre
disposition
alors madame la présidente je david et
les rapporteurs généraux vont s'exprimer
pour ma part je voudrais focaliser une
question sur un point vous avez bien
insisté sur le fait que les
administrations publiques
ces trois sous-ensembles etat sécurité
sociale collectivités territoriales
vous avez en ce qui concerne la dépense
de l'état
prix des hypothèses hypothèses
d'évolution spontanée et hypothèses de
correction s'agissant de la sécurité
sociale je n'ai pas bien compris comment
vous intégrez la réduction de
l'estimation de la croissance par
rapport à la loi de financement de la
sécurité sociale pour 2012
si j'ai bien vu votre raisonnement sur
la loi de finances je les moins bien vu
en ce qui concerne les rentrées de
recettes de la sécurité sociale
ensuite les collectivités territoriales
vous nous avez dit où vous avez laissé
entendre que si le déficit était plus
important en matière de sécurité sociale
les collectivités territoriales pourrait
éventuellement servir de régulateur vous
avez également laissé entendre dans les
pistes que vous avez tracé qu'entre les
niveaux de collectivités territoriales
et en considérant l'autonomie fiscale
variable de ses niveaux de collectivités
territoriales un traitement plus sévères
pourraient être imaginés pour les
communes et intercommunalités par
rapport aux départements et aux régions
donc monsieur le président monsieur le
président vous êtes entré dans le
domaine institutionnel et naturellement
ces sujets sont des sujets très lourd
imaginez une gouvernance partagée entre
un état une sécurité sociale des
collectivités territoriales de divers
niveaux est elle même très diverses
n'est ce pas préjuger de l'organisation
des pouvoirs publics dans ce pays
est-ce si simple et
les lignes directrices que vous avez
tracé pauvres tel s'imaginer à constance
de nos règles juridiques et
constitutionnelles il y aurait de
nombreuses autres questions à poser mais
je m'arrêterai là et bien entendu je me
tourne vers madame la présidente annie
david merci monsieur le président en
m'excusant de mon retard à cette
audition et ça va dans votre sens
monsieur le président concernant la
gageure d'un débat nous étions nous
mêmes à la commission des affaires
sociales sur un présentation d'un
rapport évidemment pas le vôtre monsieur
migaud est pas de cette nature là mais
qui concernait la loi sur le handicap la
loi de 2005 et beaucoup de mes collègues
en sont repartis frustrés parce qu en
une heure et demie nous n'avons pas eu
le temps d'aller au bout de ce débat
donc je partage votre interrogation sur
la nécessité ou pas d'ouvrir maintenant
le débat je serai plus tentée en plus au
vu de votre rapport vous dire qu'il y
aura il y a quand même deux thèmes bien
différent enfin il ya évidemment les
finances publiques il y à aussi pour ce
qui concerne la commission des affaires
sociales toute la partie de la
protection sociale dont vous avez dit
toute l'importance est justement le
report d'une année sur l'autre de la
dette notamment de l'assurance maladie
sur les générations futures donc
peut-être serait-il préférable de couper
en deux et de vous re est invité
monsieur le premier président avec
l'ensemble des personnalités qui vous
accompagne pour avoir un débat plus
approfondi mais le rapporteur général du
budget de la sécurité sociale est à mes
côtés il ne manquera pas malgré tout il
ne vous interrogez moi j'ai entendu
beaucoup de choses qui m'inquiète parce
que justement nous sortons d'un débat
sur la loi handicap où nous avons dit
les uns et des autres le manque de
financement de nos collectivités pour
pouvoir répondre à l'application
correcte de cette loi 2005 notamment en
parlant d'accessibilité et là j'entends
bien ce que vous nous dites donc voila
vous voyez un petit peu toutes les
interrogations qui peuvent nous
traverser aujourd'hui vous avez parlé
également de difficultés sur la ph sur
la pl
tous des dossiers qui nous qui nous
touchent de près et qui nous interpelle
donc voilà en ce qui me concerne je n'ai
pas de question je voudrais vous
remercier pour cette présentation est
vous dire qu'il me semble qu'avec la
commission des affaires sociales
peut-être nous vous inviterons de
nouveau pour avoir ce débat plus en
profondeur à la commission je vous
remercie monsieur le rapporteur général
françois marc
merci monsieur le président je
souhaitais remercier didier migaud
premier président de la cour des comptes
pour la clarté de son exposé qui est
certes exigeant en ce qui concerne des
efforts à entreprendre mais qui est tout
de même éclairant quant à la situation à
laquelle nous sommes et je le remercie
de la grande clarté des éléments qui
nous a fourni
il a insisté sur la responsabilité
politique dans la première partie
introductive de son exposé la
responsabilité politique et du parlement
et bien sûr de nouveaux vernant est à
cet égard je me réjouis mon ma part que
le nouveau gouvernement ait souhaité
inscrire son action dans la suite
logique de ces exigences manifester est
attendu de connaître le rapport votre
rapport monsieur le président le rapport
de la cour des comptes avant d'afficher
ses orientations qui sont appelés à
s'inscrire dans ses exigences et 10 ans
l'âge et à l'esprit mes chers collègues
que ici même dans cette salle il y a
quelques petites années nous avions
entendu un discours identique de la part
de philippe séguin qui à l'époque
présidé la cour et qui avait attiré
notre attention sur
le déficit croissant le déficit qui
explosait qui atteignait 100 milliards à
l'époque et avait insisté sur le fait
que les deux tiers des éléments de ce
déficit provenaient de décisions
conjoncturelle et qu'il convenait donc
de changer de politique
je suis au regret de constater que
certaines des préconisations faites à
l'époque n'ont pas été sans doute assez
écouté et je ne veux donc souhaité au
gouvernement actuel
une action plus ambitieuse et plus
exigeante par rapport à cette situation
qui nous est présenté je m'en tiendrais
monsieur le président vous avez insisté
sur le laps de temps très bref dans
l'eau disposons sur deux ou trois
demandes de précisions complémentaires
s'agissant tout d'abord des éléments
deux perspectives pour les mois qui
viennent le rapport monsieur le
président a conduit à corriger le la
croissance spontanée des dépenses
publiques puisque nous nous aviez parlé
dans un rapport de février 2012 d'une
croissance spontanée de 1,7 pour cent et
cette croissance a été ramenée à 1 5%
pourquoi la cour des comptes at-elle
révisé à la baisse son hypothèse de
croissance spontanée des dépenses
c'est une question ou peut-être des
précisions pourraient apporter d'autre
part s'agissant de la croissance des
dépenses publiques en 2012 dans le
rapport
la cour ne mentionne que des aléas sur
les recettes et aucun relatifs aux
dépenses pourquoi la cour des comptes
considère tel qu'il n'y a pas de risque
de dérapage des dépenses c'est peut-être
utile que vous nous préciser les raisons
enfin je voudrais insister sur un point
qui est tout même aujourd'hui assez
pénalisant pour le gouvernement qui doit
assumer ses vrilles et et budgétaire
c'est le dérapage qui ressort de
des conséquences des contentieux
notamment le contentieux sur les opcvm
il me semble bar est un sujet
relativement lourd parce que l'audit
relève effectivement l'impact de ce
contentieux communautaire sur la
législation fiscale française
5 milliards d'euros en tout dont en
décaissements prévisible à cinq
milliards dès 2012 puis 1,75 milliard en
ainsi qu'en 2014 votre document souligne
que ce contentieux a été provisionnée en
comptabilité générale à hauteur de 3
milliards 3 d'euros à fin 2011 ce qui
montre que le risque de perdre n'était
pas négligé par le précédent
gouvernement
pourtant celui-ci n'a rien fait pour
prévenir l'augmentation de ce risque en
arrêtant le compteur de l'imposition non
conforme au droit communautaire et en
lui substituant une recette plus pérenne
et plus solides ainsi cette année encore
l'état va encaisser 800 millions d'euros
dont nous savons qu'il devra les
rembourser avec intérêts il s'agit d'une
gestion curieuse et sur ce point il est
clair que ça tranche avec ce qu'on a pu
voir dans le passé notamment sur l'avoir
fiscal qui avait été supprimée dès qu'un
risque de condamnation était apparue dès
lors sur le premier président vos
travaux vous ont-ils permis de savoir
depuis quand le risque de défaite sur le
contentieux opcvm été analysé comme
sérieux à bercy et pourquoi le précédent
gouvernement a préféré fermer les yeux
sur ce sujet laissant à son successeur
une ardoise de 5 milliards
enfin dernier point sur les
collectivités je rejoins ce qu'a dit
notre président de commission des
finances s'agissant de la
différenciation des concours de l'état
en fonction de la situation des
collectivités
la question se pose de savoir de quelle
façon on va différencier les
collectivités les unes par rapport aux
autres
les moyens qui vont être mis à leur
disposition
s'agit-il de proposer par exemple des
taux de remboursement différents pour le
fctva de réduire plus significativement
encore les part forfaitaire de dgf de
faire évoluer différemment les parts dgf
forfaitaire des départements par rapport
aux communes bref pouvez vous nous en
dire un peu plus sur ce point et enfin
quant à la réduction des dépenses
publiques locales
vous comprendrez que nous sommes un peu
interrogatif ici au sénat sur ce point
puisque la cour préconise dans son
rapport la réduction de ses dépenses
pourtant je le premie monsieur le
premier président la cour confirme que
la perspective d'un solde nul des
administrations locales est plausible
pour 2013 que la situation financière
des collectivités territoriales est
saine et que les comptes des
administrations publiques locales sont
structurellement équilibré dans ce ces
conditions la diminution de la dépense
locale qui est préconisé doit-elle être
vraiment considérée comme une priorité
nous nous interrogeons sur ce point
et en effet monsieur le rapporteur
général d'autant plus que s'agissant de
l'état on nous parle de dépenses
constantes en volume
voir en valeur et s'agissant des
collectivités territoriales il s'agirait
d'une diminution si j'ai bien compris
monsieur le premier président la parole
est au rapporteur général yves daudigny
merci monsieur le président monsieur le
premier président nous vous avons écouté
avec la plus grande attention il n'y a
pas de surprise fondamental dans le rock
dans le rapport la cour
même si j'évoque bien sûr là les comptes
sociaux
l'inquiétude est peut-être plus forte
que prévu à la prise de connaissance
d'un certain nombre d'éléments comme par
exemple l'évolution de la branche
vieillesse branche retraite dans les
années à venir
le constat dans votre rapport effet que
la dégradation de la conjoncture
pourrait aggraver de 2 milliards le
déficit des comptes sociaux en 2012
s'agissant d'évolutions à moyen terme
il confirme ce qui avait été pressenti
lors du plfss à savoir le maintien
durable de lourds déficits
au delà de 2013 en l'absence de fortes
mesures correctrices
il est essentiel de souligner que comme
l'an passé la cour estime qu'il faut
rééquilibrer en priorité les comptes
sociaux dans la mesure où financé à
crédit des dépenses courantes de
prestations sociales et je reprends
votre expression une anomalie profonde
c'est une évidence mais il faut le
rappeler
le rapport met en évidence les
évolutions assez distinctes entre les
branches de la sécurité sociale pour les
branches retraite et famille
il ne décèle aucune tendance à la
résorption du déficit après 2013 pour
l'assurance-maladie de retour à
l'équilibré serait plus ou moins long
selon l'évolution de lanvin vous l'avez
rappelé il y à quelques instants alors
trois questions la première le rapport
estime qu'il faudrait contenir la
progression de l'ondam à 2 5% par an
avec une progression spontanée des
dépenses plutôt de 3 5 à 4% par an cette
situation et
liée à des évolutions de fond vous les
avez rappelé vieillissement maladies
chroniques nouveaux traitements
pensez vous que les mesures
structurelles que vous proposez par
exemple donc meilleure coordination
ville-hôpital suffiront à réduire cette
évolution divergente
ou bien ne faut-il pas envisager
d'autres leviers deuxième question le
rapport indique que la branche famille
ne peut pas retrouver l'équilibré car
lui a été retiré une part de csg et
attribuer des recettes aux rendements
décroissants
il suggère dans le même temps de revoir
l'indexation des prestations pour
limiter la progression des dépenses ne
pensez vous pas qu'il serait préférable
de redonner à la branche maladie des
recettes plus stable et enfin troisième
question la dette sociale va
certainement point d'interrogation
continuer à progresser dans des
proportions qui dépendront de la
capacité à réduire les déficits
de votre point de vue par quel type de
prélèvement faudra-t-il ou faudrait-il
financer cette dette supplémentaire
merci beaucoup
un monsieur daudigny et contrairement l
usage nous pourrions peut-être 30 dans
la foulée les questions des membres de
nos commissions et et monsieur le
premier président répondra à l'ensemble
à toute la série s'il le veut bien
alors j'ai des demandes de parole de
fabienne keller christian bourquin
vincent de lège voix marie-hélène des
esgaulx
y at il d'autres demandes de parole jean
paul emorine madame
michel andré c'est ça qui est y at il
d'autres demandes plait-il serge larcher
georges patient pardon excusez moi ce
qu'on pourrait voir la pièce il d'autres
demandes de parole ne pouvait pas
emporté ce sont deux questions que très
important à tenir par en faire une autre
nous viendrait attendez je vous demande
s'il ya des demandes de parole se marie
en a beaucoup que nous avons nourri
auditionneront bien entendu monsieur
didier migaud
cela va de soi et et d'ailleurs c'est
toujours un plaisir de l'accueillir
quelles que soient les messages qu'il
nous transmet mille nous transmet des
messages de vérité alors je passe la
parole à fabienne keller
monsieur le président messieurs les les
magistrats madame et messieurs les
présidents
si vous le permettez mes chers collègues
si nous y maintenant d'une autre chacun
peut poser sa question premier pendant
de répondre très raisonnablement et nous
ne dépasserons pas leur sacro-sainte de
13 heures j'ai le président votre seul
président oui vous avez membres et pour
une question d'ordre oui ce serait une
question d'ordre écouter il me semble
que compte tenu du délai si on regarde
13 heures il serait peut-être
souhaitable que nos invités répondent à
vos questions qui nous semble donc à
retrouver ce que nous aurions peut-être
dans le détail reposer comme
problématique
donc je me demande s'il serait pas plus
simple contenu de ce délai de répondre
tout de suite à vos questions deux
rapporteurs et de président il me semble
que ça ça serait préférable et c'est
pour cela que se demander la parole
monsieur le président
madame michèle andré a pris la parole je
le note ont écouté il y à peu
d'intervenants je crois que chacun sera
raisonnable héééé aie aie aie aie aie
je crains beaucoup la frustration de nos
collègues qui viennent et qui ont sans
doute besoin de s'exprimer
ils vont le faire très raisonnablement
il n'y a pas de doute
monsieur christian bourquin vous avez
demandé la parole monsieur le premier
président vous nous avez clairement
exprimée dans votre rapport la priorité
quitté rétablir les comptes au niveau de
l'état et des comptes sociaux
vous avez évoqué également ce
rééquilibrage cette régulation des
collectes par les collectivités
territoriales permettez moi de vous
poser de rentrer dans ce secteur là est
à moi même président d'une région
on est bien conscient qu'il y à des
données exceptionnelles et des moments
exceptionnels tout le monde ne faut pas
étouffer la croissance vous l'avez dit
photo il faut répondre à la norme
pourtant c'est nous qui les dictons
parent aux différentes lois il y a eu
des transferts qui s'impose à nous dans
notre république il nous faut faire un
effort
j'ai bien entendu le propos de monsieur
le rapporteur général qui disait
pourtant nous avons des comptes
équilibrés dans les collectivités c'est
pas nous qui avons assuré l'essentiel de
cette vie à déficit mais je tenais à
vous faire ce sentiment vous dire ce
sentiment qui est un sentiment qui
participera pas à à trouver la solution
la solution s'il vous plaît les élus de
la france et ils sont nombreux
collectivités territoriales sont très
contrariée quand on les accusait ci est
de droite et de gauche d'avoir participé
à une situation alors qu'ils ont des
comptes équilibrés
ma question est toute simple
pensez-vous vous les chambres régionales
des comptes être armé en région pour
conseiller q tilman à des améliorations
sur l'eau pointe
je vous pose cette question parce qu'il
faut partager les efforts mais
aujourd'hui on est trop habitués à avoir
vos chambres sur les élus nous dresser
une vindicte pour sur des bons mots qui
sont relayées par la presse mais qui
participe à aucune amélioration
est-ce que déjà on peut assainir cela
pour qu'on travaille en confiance je
suis trop témoin de rapport ou nous
contenons dosettes café
en fait on ne dit pas et on partage pas
un avenir qui permettrait à chaque
région
à chaque département de participer
sérieusement à ce redressement
c'est peut-être à la marge de toute la
problématique énorme mais je voulais
participer également à à cela par cette
question
si monsieur bourquin la parole est à
fabienne keller
monsieur le président messieurs les
magistrats madame et messieurs les
présidents messieurs présent vous avez
évoqué le risque d'un effet négatif sur
la croissance d'une réduction du déficit
est rappelé que le gouvernement doit
rétablir 2 équilibre le budget mais
aussi la compétitivité
s'appuyant notamment sur les travaux
remarquables comparant la situation
française
la situation allemande sur ce sujet
quelle est votre analyse du dispositif
qui vise à élargir la base de la
fiscalité je pense très concrètement à
la réduction des cotisations de la
branche famille
remplacé par une tva anti délocalisation
élargissant de ce fait la base fiscale à
l'emploi qui n'est pas situé chez nous
je vous remercie
merci à fabienne keller la parole et à
20,7 de l'aide
puisque vous
is the way bon alors c'est enfin 12 -
alors la parole est à georges patient
parmi les mesures préconisées de
réduction des dépenses publiques
vous avez cité les niches fiscales
et parmi les niches fiscales vous avez
cités en premier lieu l'investissement
outre-mer
alors est ce que ce sont ces niches qui
sont les plus coûteuses est ce que vous
avez pu mesurer l'impact de ces niches
en termes d'emploi et de développement
économiques
et puis s'il fallait les réduiront les
supprimer est-ce qu'il reviendrait pas
plus cher au budget d'aller vers les
dépenses budgétaires
c'est à georges patient la parole est à
marie-hélène des esgaulx
merci le président monsieur le premier
président je voudrais d'abord saluer la
qualité de du rapport que vous avez
présenté et son importante contribution
au titre des enjeux pour le respect
d'une trajectoire des finances publiques
vers l' équilibre sur ce que vous avez
dit au titre des perspectives de 2013 je
vous cite que vous avez dit la cour a
toujours considéré que le levier de la
maîtrise des dépenses devrait jouer un
rôle essentiel donc je m'arrête sur ce
point qui de notre point de vue est très
important et je retiens que si on fait
un partage égal entre mesures sur les
recettes et mesures sur les dépenses
ce sont 16 milliards et demi d'euros
d'économies sur les dépenses qui devront
être réalisés et c'est un effort qui
revient simplement à stabilisé en volume
les dépenses publiques de leurs ans dans
leur ensemble c'est à dire à faire en
sorte qu'elle n'évolue pas plus vite que
l'inflation
dans ma question c'est ce partage égal
n'est-il pas en fait du point de vue de
la cour un effort minimum entreprendre
si à marie hélène des esgaulx et enfin
dernier orateurs inscrits jean paul
emorine le président et maureen oui
merci monsieur le président ce prêt
premier président de la cour des comptes
ce la question c'est très simple par
rapport à vos recommandations
il se trouve que l'état est actionnaire
à antrain avec l' agence de
participation de l'état et l'état est
actionnaire dans des entreprises
importantes souvent à 100% souvent 1 60%
et quand on regarde ce qui se passe au
niveau européen tous les pays qui
connaissent des difficultés on leur
demande d'aller vers des privatisations
à moins que ce président je ne parle pas
de privatisation mais au moins
d'ouverture du capital
quand on voit que l'état est encore
actionnaire à 93% chez areva ou encore à
85%
edf on voit bien que des marges de
manoeuvre ce président ne soyez pas
inquiet j'ai posé les mêmes questions
précédent gouvernement et je pense
qu'ici il ya peut-être des dd des
capitaux a retrouvé à ouvrir le capital
de ses entreprises et peut-être donné
quand même de nouvelles recettes au
gouvernement ticulier pour financer les
investissements le cas échéant voilà
monsieur le premier président nous y
sommes arrivés
vous avez 16 minutes pour répondre à
l'ensemble des questions
c'est plus qu'il n'en faut certainement
diversifier le président je remercie
aussi l'ensemble de celles et ceux qui
ont posé les questions je vais essayer
d'y répondre mais je vous redis toute
notre disponibilité d'ailleurs nous
avons déjà des rendez vous programmé
avec la commission des affaires sociales
notamment sur la certification des
comptes de la sécurité sociale alors par
rapport aux questions que vous avez posé
monsieur le président sur les
moins-values de recettes alors 6 à 10
milliards d'euros c'est tout a pu
confondues tout m'a plu confondues il ya
de l'ordre de 0,8 pour ce qui concerne
la sécurité sociale 1 2 concernant les
dmt au bon donc ce sont les départements
qui sont concernés et le reste concerne
l'état essentiellement
lles est un peu de tva mais
essentiellement l'impôt sur les sociétés
le améliorer la gouvernance des finances
publiques c'est une question qui était
posée par plusieurs d'entre vous oui ça
nous apparaît nécessaire
bon pour pour une raison bien 5 comment
pouvez vous conduire un redressement en
laissant de côté 25% des administrations
publiques donc il est nécessaire de
trouver d'autres règles pour piloter les
finances publiques est d'impliquer tout
le monde donc
la france ne peut pas s'engager sur une
trajectoire et puis ne pas pouvoir au
niveau national bon se donner les moyens
du respect de ce pilotage
ça nous apparaît tout à fait possible ce
n'est pas plus compliqué nous
semble-t-il en france que chez nos
voisins qui y arrivent alors même
d'ailleurs que ce sont parfois des états
fédéraux et j'y arrive pourtant bon donc
voilà donc cessé au tout cas vous devez
réfléchir
la cour peut le cas échéant vous vous
aider aussi à y réfléchir
sachant qu y compris notamment avec des
collectivités territoriales tout n'est
pas affaire de normes contraignantes ont
peut-être une démarche contractuelle
aussi peut en tout cas être tenté dans
un premier temps pour faire en sorte que
les les engagements soient soient
respectés et qui monsieur le premier
président va signer le contrat du côté
des collectivités territoriales qui les
représentent
qui veut s'engager pour elle je veux
dire est ce que languedoc roussillon
peut s'engager pour la bretagne
la drôme pour la lozère
en plein pour chaumont en haute-marne
président ce sont des questions qui je
crois s'adresse en premier lieu à
l'autorité politique bon gouvernement et
parlement nathan débats de la cour des
comptes qu'elle se substitue à vous pour
y apporter les réponses moi ce que je
sais c'est face de la courbe peut dire
c'est quand la france signe bon ça
langage bon et donc c'est à l'autorité
politique de faire en sorte que cet
engagement soit tenu parce que sinon
c'est une question bien évidemment de
crédibilité à la fois vis-à-vis des
partenaires européens et puis vis-à-vis
des créanciers et à partir du moment où
vous perdez votre crédibilité
il peut y avoir des conséquences bien
évidemment sur sur votre votre tête
alors madame la présidente lamartine
david a entendu beaucoup de choses
inquiétantes at elle dit bon c'est c'est
de notre responsabilité en tout cas que
de vous poser les termes je dirais du
débat que vous devez que vous devez
avoir
vous avez évoqué le la politique de
handicap
c'est un merveilleux exemple
d'enchevêtrement les compétences c'est à
l'état qui participe à hauteur de
pratiquement 13 milliards d'euros vous
avez bien évidemment la sécurité sociale
vont hauteur de 9 milliards vous avez
aussi bons les collectivités
territoriales les départements les
régions on voit est ce que l'on voit est
ce qu'il n'ya pas on le voit bien dans
d'autres politiques
est-ce que ce foisonnement est toujours
justifiée
est ce que à travers une plus grande
clarification des compétences entre les
uns et les autres
bon il n'y a pas une action publique qui
pourrait être plus efficace tout en
n'étant pas plus cher bon donc c'est une
des questions qui quittent effectivement
peut-être peut-être poser sur les
questions de monsieur le rapporteur
général de la commission de 2 des
finances
bon sur ce que vous avez dit sur les sur
les contentieux jeu dont acte je n'ai
rien à redire
bon tous ces éléments là se trouvent
dans le rapport de la cour il y à 600
millions d'euros à inscrire sur l'année
un qui manque en tout cas on état actuel
des des choses les éléments étaient
connus à la fin de l'année 2011
en tout cas au début de l'année 2012
avant le vote des lois de finances
rectificative je ne peux que que
confirmer cela sur la dépense vous avez
repris ce que nous avons dit nous avons
identifié un certain nombre de de risque
de dépassement ou dessous budgétisation
ou d'un pass mon de l'ordre de 1 à 2
milliards
vous les avez dans les annexes ce que
nous disons c'est que c'est un peu près
du même ordre de grandeur
malheureusement chaque année bon et
chaque année il ya des observations de
la cour
bon donc c'est malheureusement habituels
ce sont des des dépassements des risques
qui sont gérables dans dans le cadre je
dirais de l'ensemble des enveloppes dans
le cadre de la réserve de précaution
même s'il peut paraître aux prunes en de
l'augmenter de l'ordre de 1 milliard
d'euros à travers notamment des gels
supplémentaire de deux crédits mais ça
ne l'apparaît
gérable à partir du moment où bien sûr
une extrême vigilance et est apportée
sur dans l'évolution de l'exécution de
la dépense et puis où toute dépense
nouvelle et d'effectivement financé soit
par déploiement soit le cas échéant par
une recette nouvelle même si la cour a
toujours une préférence bien évidemment
pour les redéploiements
voilà pour l'audition de didier migaud
par les sénateurs de la commission des
finances si vous souhaitez revoir cette
audition elle est disponible en vidéo à
la demande sur notre site internet
publicsenat.fr
je vous retrouve cet après midi à partir
de 14h30 pour une après-midi et bien
spéciale lecture de la déclaration de
jean marc ayrault le premier ministre
qui va donc s'adresser
cet après midi au sénateur bonne journée
à tous